[ THUNDER ]
♪♪♪
>>OH HUSH, LITTLE ONE.
DON'T CRY, YOU'RE A PRINCESS!
AND NO ONE CAN EVER HURT YOU.
♪♪♪
NO.
>> PLEASED TO MAKE YOUR
ACQUAINTANCE, YOUR MAJESTY.
I'VE BROUGHT YOU A GIFT!
>> NO!
THE CURSE!!!
>> HA HA HA HA HA!!
♪♪♪
>> PRINCESS VIOLA --
>> MY PRINCE!
I'VE MISSED YOU SO BUT YOU MUST
LEAVE -- IT'S ALMOST DARK.
>> BUT WHY DO YOUR ALWAYS MAKE
ME LEAVE?
>> DON'T ASK ME THESE QUESTIONS,
MY PRINCE.
>> WELL LET ME ASK YOU THIS
ONE --
PRINCESS VIOLA, WILL YOU BE MY
BRIDE?
>> OH PRINCE BENEDICT, NOTHING
WOULD BRING ME MORE JOY.
BUT, I HAVE A TERRIBLE SECRET.
IF YOU KNEW IT, YOU'D NEVER WANT
TO SEE ME AGAIN.
>> NONSENSE!
>> YOU SEE, MY LOVE, SHORTLY
AFTER MY BIRTH, I WAS CURSED BY
AN SORCERESS.
>> NO CURSE COULD KEEP ME FROM
LOVING YOU.
>> YOU SEE, AS SOON AS NIGHT
FALLS I -- I BECOME SOMETHING
ELSE. I -- TRANSFORM.
>> WHAT DO YOU BECOME?
A BEAST?
AN OGRE?
WHATEVER IT IS, NOTHING CAN KEEP
ME FROM LOVING YOU.
>> YOU SWEAR?
>> I SWEAR ON ONE THOUSAND
LIFETIMES, THAT I WILL LOVE YOU
TIL THE DAY I DIE.
>> WELL, OKAY.
I BECOME -- ME, BUT FIFTEEN
POUNDS HEAVIER.
>> OH.
>> BUT I AM SO RELIEVED TO HEAR
YOU DON'T CARE!
>> UH-HUH.
>> THAT I'LL BE YOURS AND YOU'LL
BE MINE FOREVER.
>> HMM.
>> IS THAT A PROBLEM?
>> OF COURSE NOT, MY DEAR.
THERE ARE MUCH MORE HORRID
CREATURES YOU COULD BECOME.
JUST -- FIFTEEN POUNDS WHERE?
>> WHAT?
>> IS IT LIKE, IS IT JUST IN
YOUR BUTT, OR BOOBS?
>> NO IT'S KIND OF ALL OVER.
>> GOT IT.
>> SOME PEOPLE SAY I LOOK BETTER
WITH THE 15 POUNDS.
>> OH, LIKE, YOUR FRIENDS?
OH DANG.
I JUST REALIZED, I HAVE A THING
UNTIL THE END OF TIME.
>> I KNEW IT, I'VE LOST YOU.
[ THUNDER ]
>> THERE IS ONE WAY TO BREAK THE
SPELL.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO SO, YOU MUST
MAKE A SACRIFICE, DEAR PRINCE.
>> I WILL DO ANYTHING IF IT
FREES THE PRINCESS FROM THIS
TERRIBLE
CURSE.
>> AT NIGHT, YOU WILL LOSE ONE
QUARTER OF AN INCH OF FROM YOUR
PENIS.
>> NO.
>> OH YEAH, NO WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO LOSE THAT.
>> HA HA HA!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]